- Hey, Rachel.
Can you make 10 copies
of this script for me?
- Yes, of course, I definitely can.
At your service, Mr. Kane. You da man.
Gonna get right to it.
Oh no! I'm so tired.
I barely had any time to
sleep from file transfers,
to prop runs, to making copies.
There's just so much to do,
but I want to do my best.
Which means never saying no.
- Can you pick up a package?
- Yes.
- Can you sync these files?
- How was your weekend?
- Yes.
(snoring)
- Rachel?
(screams)
- Oh, I'm just mediating.
A quick little meditation to
get the ol' noggin working.
Zoom zoom. Steve Jobs, Gandhi?
They all did it.
(humming)
- Um, okay. I'm gonna need
two packs of water balloons,
and a can of whip cream for my shoot.
Can you pick that up for me?
- Oh, Michelle. I can do
anything you want me to do.
I can do this. I got me
my fourth cup of coffee.
Can't let my work fam down.
I've been pretty on top of
things. Pretty darn focused.
I'm just, like, nailing life, you know?
- Hey, Rachel.
- Oh my god, I'm so sorry.
- It's alright, wait, what's wrong?
I'm pretty worried about Rachel.
I can usually sense
when something's wrong.
What's going on? Is everything alright?
- Um, I'm fine.
- Don't you dare lie to
me, Rachel J uhn Kane.
I'm very in-tuned to human idiosyncrasies.
- Okay, I've been skipping
a few hours here and there,
but it's no biggie.
I just have a lot to
do for Kane and Jenny.
- Why haven't you told them it's too much?
- I don't know. I just didn't
want to disappoint anyone.
- Well, you're disappointing me now.
By not putting your
health first and foremost.
- I'm sorry, Jeremy.
- It's okay. Now, go home.
I'll talk to Kane and
Jenny about lightening up
your workload.
Just next time, tell them
that, like, it's too much.
- You're the best, Jeremy.
You're a real good big brother.
- I'm totally, deeply in love with Rachel.
(gypsy music)